Now that we have an idea of what our graph will mean, I've gone ahead and drawn
it for you. Know that the graph looks like it's made up of pieces of four
different lines with different slopes. And in fact, it's exactly what's
happening. So, we can see how they all compare to one another. I'd like you
tell me what the equation in for each part of the line is. Remember that the
slope of each line will be the tax rate of the bracket that corresponds to it
written in decimal form. If you figured this out for each line segment, and
then simply find a point on each of these sections of the line, you can use the
point-slope formula to find the equation of the line. Please use x for the
income, which is on the horizontal axis and t for taxes owed, since it's on the
vertical axis.